i think decentralization needs to happen
it needs to happen fast i think people
need to get out of cities i think they
need to go to
more rural areas they need to start
learning how to take care of themselves
and be self-sufficient and so we got rid
of one of our we have
you know two we have a front lawn it's
there's a walkway dividing the lawn we
got rid of one side of it and turned it
into a garden
so we're gonna be growing a lot of our
own food not nearly enough to sustain
the amount of people who are
you know living and working but it's a
start and i think people need to do that
we also have chickens so we're gonna
have a bunch of eggs
uh at some point the next couple of
months and i think having some reliance
on yourself is really important
and getting off the grid i don't i don't
mean
getting off the grid in the sense of
like disappearing from society
i mean having well water with a
filtration system
and having some kind of you know at-home
renewable of solar or wind or whatever
you can get
and still being attached to the grid
just having the capability to survive on
your own in the event
things start falling apart yeah the
electric grid especially right
because right now if one part of the
electrical goes down they shut the
entire grid down to repair it and take
everyone's power out that's not
sustainable or there's a storm and it
could knock out your power and what are
you gonna do
so i'm thinking about what we're seeing
with the market um
there's there's desperate attempts to
assuage the fears of an impending market
collapse and hyperinflation
and i i think it's coming i think we're
starting to see a lot of the same signs
far be it for me to tell anybody what
they should do with their money but you
know i've been talking to a lot of my
friends
who are uh you know some of them who do
and are day traders and work in
investment firms
and they they bring up you know every
time we see a major collapse
you start seeing similar signs of the
media saying oh no everything's fine
there's no collapse
just keep doing your thing and it's like
when they start saying this stuff
everything's okay go back to work do
mind your own business
it happens every time and then there's a
major collapse or some kind of crap
there was a case uh
i was meant talking about christopher
mellon who was just on rogan like a
couple days ago and he told this story
where
because this guy worked in intelligence
agencies they told him
that there was a pending nuclear attack
on new york
and dc and they told and so he had his
whole when when when uh i don't remember
what year he said
but he but he was told from the inside
that this is
likely to be happening and so he like
told his family and friends but like
he said he was walking around sort of in
a blur because
he you know it was surreal he felt like
he should warn people but
it would cause more chaos that's why
they but that did happen
that's confirmed from the inside they
knew nuclear was a
was a tangible threat and they decided
not to tell anyone because they figured
they didn't they didn't have years ago
five years ago 10 years ago if maybe
lydia can help look up the
the date but like during the i mean i
think he might have even broken the news
like
two days ago so i'm not sure but
you know they didn't have full
confirmation that the attack was coming
so they decided that it wasn't worth it
because their level of intelligence
wasn't guaranteed and then luckily it
ended up not happening
that's why i think you know the preppers
are laughing at us
because they're like you got these
arrogant city folk who mock preppers
and it's just like first of all why do i
care what you think about me
second of all when you when when the
water shuts off the power goes out like
when hurricane sandy hit and the power
went out in new york
it hurt like no none of these proper
people care when there's a hurricane
like and
they got everything they could they're
they're they're good they go underground
the joke's on the people mocking it's
really yeah they're not they're not
prepared
like preppers truthers like when i
remember when truther became
a word that was like a pejorative i mean
that's that's out of a fiction novel
truther i mean granted okay there are
there are some like crazy truthers about
certain topics
but like the fact that the phrase
truther
is used as a pejorative is insane when
you just look at it
from the outside i'll tell you what's
insane there was that quote from joe
biden recently where he's like
who needs a hundred rounds what do you
think the deer is wearing kevlar
it's like uh your life has been so cushy
and soft you've been such a spoiled
pampered brat
because you do not know hardship that
you're like why would anyone ever need
to defend their lives
well i guess you can ask the the the the
people in
inner city chicago why they keep buying
illegal guns and bringing them in and
buying them
because there's a lot of gun violence
and they're worried some people are bad
people and want to commit crimes and
some people are worried about being the
victims of crime
but that statement from joe biden just
shows that's the mentality
they've never had hardship imagine
spending your whole life you know i'll
put it this way
i know a lot of people who never had
jobs
this crazy 26 27 year old never had a
job wow why they went to school they
went to high school they went to college
went to a master's program get out
24 to 26 never had a job ever
so they have no idea how anything works
they have no idea how to get money and
they're just men
adults at 26 who don't know how to
survive on their own
now that is obvious you can see that you
can be like obviously if you've never
worked and never you know generated
income
you're going to be a 26 year old with
all of life's responsibilities out of
school and having no idea what to do
sure they can teach you how to play the
trombone in college or they can teach
you how to like you know set up a
nuclear reactor but they don't tell you
how to get a job or make money or you
know set up a banking account or pay
your taxes
and now you think about that and think
about conflict in crisis
not not not not a person in this country
save
cops veterans and not even every veteran
a lot of them are administrative a lot
of cops are administrative there's
a relatively small fraction of people in
this country who have actually
experienced any kind of real conflict
so most people in this country are
voting based on
the the idea that everything is and
always will be fine
because it is normal to not have to
worry about any of these things
it's normal yeah and that's why
decentralized decentralization is
something you're sort of forced to learn
whether it's digital decentralization or
physical
you know with farms and stuff like you
have to get banned in in order
or or you have to know people who are
getting banned
in order to understand that you need to
secure yourself
and your communication system that's why
it's funny when you you know i was
talking about contra points earlier
on one of my channels contra points is a
leftist
who if you if you look at her twitter
accounts i search for free speech
there's just mockery
of the free speech warriors now all of a
sudden after one of her videos is age
restricted it's we must stand up for
free speech and the left
must reclaim free speech and it's like
my response is always thank you welcome
to the fight
please your advocacy for free speech is
greatly welcomed but if only you stopped
treating this like a like a joke in a
game and that's the point
people who weren't being oppressed the
people who weren't
being targeted by a system who did not
know hardship were laughing at those who
were saying we need to be prepared and
fight this
because they weren't experiencing the
problems this is the funny thing now
you you can you can see something so
plainly obvious what do you do when the
power goes out i don't know the power
never goes out if it does someone fixes
it for me
what do you do when the power goes out
and doesn't come back on
what are you some kind of dumb prepper
okay well listen
you can keep betting on this idea that
life is and always will be a golden age
just for you
or you can look at history and recognize
for one golden age has come to an end
and two the natural state of life on
this planet is
constantly stressed out running and
struggling to survive
i did play a game of sieve where i went
from golden age to golden age to golden
age to golden age for like thousands
thousands of years yeah what was yours
what was your strategy i don't know i
was planning on easy
it was cultural science based culture
and science yeah
yeah you're playing an easy mug i think
i was playing like normal like prince or
something
above average not hard not super hard i
think it's the same reason people sit
on big tech apps because they have no
reason to leave
i mean they haven't experienced what
people involved in these issues have
experienced they're not
you know real journalists who have
experienced
censorship in international countries
i'm talking about international
journalists who are like
you know really getting censored by
governments and whatnot and so
you know you have to experience it you
see that really there's a really great
video from last year
where someone from the bbc is
interviewing the president of azerbaijan
and they're like your your record on the
on press freedom is abhorrent and he was
like what about julian assange
and then it's just like mike drop he's
like you've had this guy locked up for
how many years
holding him up holding it holding him as
a hostage and then you're gonna talk to
us about press freedoms and she's like
well
i'm not holding up your country is doing
it so don't come to me and criticize me
and it's like i'm pretty sure they have
a very bad track record on journalism so
they don't get any free passes
but why should the uk why should you
know the
any one of these these these countries
or the the us even
pretend that they're doing well now keep
in mind i love when the left claims like
press freedoms in the u.s under trump
slipped worse than somalia or whatever
stupid garbage they were saying
what you have now there was there was a
tweet from this journalist
and she was like i ordered a bulletproof
vest that i need for doing journalism in
america and it was too small
and i was i was at one point kind of
glad it was too small that my
bulletproof vest that i need for
journalism in america wasn't going to
fit me and i'm like
it's too big she was she was too small
yeah it was too big for her
uh the point is the the the she was
clearly trying to make a point about
i can't believe people in america would
need to wear a bulletproof vest
what do you think the world is like this
is like someone living
in a chuck e cheese's in the bounty in
the bouncy castle being like
why would anyone need a helmet i guess
we're in a bouncy castle you want to
protect your kids
outside is concrete like you want to
protect the minds of children like you
don't want to show them
soldiers getting blown apart and
bleeding out and stuff when they're one
so that it warps their perception
but you you also don't want to coddle
them and not show them any of the terror
of reality
in my opinion i don't have kids you have
kids you can be talk better about this
than i can
um and i don't even know like how have
you been navigating that
do you want to talk about that on yeah
like well that's kind of what was
interesting about when we all first
experienced the internet you know you go
and you find the craziest [ __ ] that you
can find
i remember like uh live leak videos man
yeah just like oh there's a guy getting
murdered again yeah he's like watching
it and just like wow
i could rail off two girls one cup
trauma oh my gosh
motorcycles hitting people in the head i
mean faces of death remember that
yeah i don't know the answer to that i
think you need to ease
a brain into the reality but
you don't you don't want to shelter them
too much that's for sure it's tough and
easy yeah
but we have a generation and we have we
have what now like three generations
of ever increasing um padded walls
so this what's happening is now you have
all these urban liberals
who it's like wall-e you know it's like
the the morbidly obese people in their
hover chairs floating around where
things are being done for them
they live in these big cities you know
what i gotta say
there's a uh covet may have been really
really bad but at least one of the
positives
because it's there's nuance in all
things i know a lot of people are gonna
be like it's
it's controversial to say that there
could be anything good coming out of
something bad no it's that these people
in cities
are going to stop wasting stop mass
consumption
and start realizing that life takes hard
work and responsibility
and you can't just sit back and let
someone else do it because you know what
happens when you do
cuomo goes and kills 15 000 people or
your guard
comes and murders like they say like
when people have bunkers and it's the
end of the world and you're relying on
your hired security
the hired security is going to come kill
you and take the bunker for themself
that's well what's part of story what's
the joke from somebody super chatted us
as i said uh on behalf of all
gun owners i'd like to thank the gun
control advocates for
stockpiling our goods for us for the
apocalypse
yeah what do you think is going to
happen when if slash when you know
there's a collapse
i think it's fun it's funny too there
was a poster on facebook and someone
mentioned something about
i think they were talking about like
dogecoin and they like this the
skyrocketing dogecoin
you got to buy this currency or buy that
currency because the dollar is in
serious trouble
and then someone laughed saying like you
guys keep talking about some kind of
like disaster collapse or civil war
and they're like where is it when's it
gonna happen and the funniest thing
about these comments that i keep hearing
from people
like where's the civil war at bro i'm
like aren't you the people obsessed
with the storming of the capital on the
sixth like clearly we're in the middle
of something
the dollar is hyper the dollar isn't
hyperinflated but it's inflating
and the cost of goods is going way up
now the gold
lumber ratio is is is you know coming
together i don't know necessarily it's a
good thing or a bad thing but we're
seeing a dramatic shift in the economy
in general
and it's it's you know you know the
craziest thing is
we've been trying to expand out here
we've been trying to find companies so
we can fix the
the the barn outside where we're gonna
be doing events we can't get anybody to
do it
we can't find anybody lumber is too
expensive steel is too expensive
we're struggling to get things done and
it's really really annoying for me
but there's a shortage we tried ordering
new computer new equipment so we can
improve the people
people have been saying like the sound
has issues on the showrock we got to get
the new equipment
right we can't get it in something is
happening
and there is a shortage of goods and
computer chips
and and merchandise and and all the
stuff is going down and then you have
these dumb people on the internet
hyper focused on whatever cnn tells them
totally ignoring whatever's happening
around them
man i can't i can't imagine what it's
going to be like for these people when
the rug gets pulled out from underneath
them that is alarming i mean because
as you know you have resources to make
these things happen
and so the fact that someone in your
position
cannot build out a barn to become i've
called
like five companies and they're like oh
man you know it's steel it's hard to get
it's really expensive right now
and i'm like can you send people out
like what you got to do
and then and so even with like getting
the website done it's like it's it's
difficult to get things to move right
now
even with like digital uh with like
software and stuff it's just
been very difficult across the board and
i remember like we
uh so one of the things one of the
issues we have the studio that we're in
is the highest point of the building and
so it gets really hot
um so we were supposed to get some kind
of like
wall-mounted ac unit that's ultra quiet
to help circulate the air and keep it
cool
company just never shows up company
doesn't show up
they come out here like oh we're we're
going to get back to you they don't show
up we had more work being done company
comes out one day just gone the next
just don't show up
and i'm like what's happening like
seriously how
i don't know that that feels like quiet
before the storm
type situation it really does what are
people doing to where the businesses
aren't functioning properly so i ordered
a new machine for this studio
uh a month and a half ago when did i say
hey guys good news in a week we're going
to be getting a new machine
ago something i don't remember there's a
chip shortage
oh yeah and so they keep saying we're
really sorry about this any day now any
dino trust us
and then we'll get it shipped out
immediately and just nothing
well i was talking uh to a guy who owns
a ford
dealership in norwalk and he was saying
that they just cannot get cars i mean
unbelievable it's like you're trying to
buy the market is there
trying to buy something and you know the
supply is not this is an existence this
is showing our softness
and our like padded walls because it's
not normal to have access to all that
stuff like that first
golden age right that's my point my
point is of a golden age no no my point
is we know it
we're talking about it i've i've been
watching this stuff in real time
so we are
moderately prepared for some kind of
serious downturn and i think it's funny
that
even after a year of a lockdown you
still have
naysayers who are like what are you some
kind of prepper it's like bro
do you remember going to the store for
toilet paper last year
do you have amnesia what's what's going
on bro
are you looking at the price of
cryptocurrencies dude
these things aren't just going up in
value because people finally realized
that they're a technology worth using
it's because people are scared of the us
dollar right now
dude you if you were on a beach and you
saw a tsunami coming that was
thousands of feet high how would you
react
and i think that's what society people
are doing as society now and you'd have
people
walking out into the water like their
brains would break their minds
actually being out in the ocean
is a safe place to be you'd take your um
surfboard and dive it and
ride it right well not you don't you
want to be hit by a tsunami but when
there's
boats that are a few miles out when the
tsunami comes they stay
you know it goes under them or goes past
them when you're faced with the
impending destruction of everything
um how would you react and i think these
people are kind of seeing it's such a
big problem that their minds can't
calculate it and so they just ridicule
there's a there's an interesting
question i can't remember where it was
posed but they said if you were sitting
in unica city and you saw like an icbm
coming right down
about to hit your you know the downtown
area from wherever you were
which which direction would you run and
the point was that if you truly
understood the power and the range of
the icbm you would run towards it
you know why because you'd be getting
away from the blast radius no no running
towards the explosion oh i thought you
meant the missile
yeah if you saw a missile heading
towards your city depending on how close
you were to city center
you would probably want to run towards
it you know why to get vaporized to get
vaporized
otherwise you can just sit there and get
radiation burns and slowly melt and
suffer for several hours by debris yeah
so i
remember i think of the new york times
did this where they talked about the the
the blast radius of your standard icbms
and they like talked about the different
kinds of missiles
and there's the initial blast radius
which vaporizes everything
then there's the belt radius wherever
like you would slowly just watch
yourself melt in
extreme suffering for like an hour and
then outside of that is the radiation
poisoning where you get to live for a
little while as your the
your dna fractures and cracks and then
you just suffer for a long time
so i just bring that up to your
reference about a tsunami
depending on where you were you can
accept your fate and try and get it over
with quickly
or you can run and try and survive it's
tough
it's it's hard to know to do but i think
most people would just say try and
survive
always no matter what but when you're
faced with something where there's no
survival is not an option
and you're just like okay there it is
this is it
how do you respond do you acknowledge it
do you still logically try and formulate
a solution can you
uh well are you uh or do you just break
i think it depends on
you know i think it's a rhetorical
question have you ever seen that that
meme where it's a bell curve
of iq at the very back it's this like
deranged looking person who
you know seems to be kind of messed up
iq 0 and they say god is real
then in the middle it's the average iq
and a person saying i'm an atheist
and then all at the high end it's a
person with a gigantic brain saying god
is real
yeah i think it's kind of like that i
think a lot of really smart i'm not
saying religious but like a lot of
really smart
and philosophically mature individuals
would see the the sun exploding and the
wave coming towards them and they'd sit
down and
close their eyes then you'd have a lot
of really dumb people who would probably
sit down and be like wow and they closed
their eyes
and then you have a lot of average
people who would be screaming and
flailing and ranting not understanding
what to do
the midwits the people of slightly above
intelligence who know just enough but
not enough
they know enough to repeat what they've
heard i think they're smart
yeah it's crazy that like not even
countries are
sort of immune to all this and so i
think it'll be really interesting to see
which countries adopt crypto and bitcoin
because the ones that do
are going to lead the future that's just
a fact it's
it's a more resilient infrastructure
it's better
tech so if they just ignore the problem
they're gonna they're gonna get left
behind if i was a conspiracy theorist
i would if i was to push one i would say
that
they the there's special interests that
want a total collapse of the us
and the global economy so that they
could have a some kind of reset
like a great resource yeah maybe like a
great reason that just resets global
capitalism with a new system
you would need a new currency and
obviously the authoritarians would want
to be able to track
every transaction so they would need
some kind of like public ledger
um like a chain of maybe like blocks
where you can see each transaction would
you call it though um
well because it's a reference to like
you know computers
and chain block well no no because it's
a reference to computers but also
currency it would be something like
byte or like bit and then like money or
coins maybe like
bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin something like
that yes
that's what i would call it so you
create a trackable currency and then
wipe out fiat and put everyone on the
trackable currency
yeah yeah then then you know what
everyone is spending at all times of
course people would try and create
things like monero
they would try and you know uh use
alternative currencies
that retain value because they're uh
they can't be duplicated
but uh ultimately i think bitcoin is
i think bitcoin's gonna hit a million
bucks and i think the reason it is
because
we need uh i mean the the government
would love
to have this system this global well
transfer of value
that they can easily watch and everyone
can watch and it's the panopticon
it's in yeah there are benefits to them
but that's why they're going to be
launching their own digital current
digital currencies that are not bitcoin
because they don't control bitcoin it's
the reality there are surveillance
benefits that they get from bitcoin but
they don't
bitcoin empowers the the people of the
world bitcoins much
more if bitcoin was not created by the
government and conspiracy that's right
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you